pully bas vous sortez de la commission
mixte paritaire avec les députés sur le
projet de loi d'état d'urgence sanitaire
vous avez notamment défendu un point
précis la nécessité de repasser devant
le parlement le 8 décembre en cas de
prolongation du confinement est ce que
ce point a pu être retenu
non il n'a pas été retenu la vie des
français vous le verset par l'épidémie
elle est aussi bouleversée par les
restrictions qui sont apportées à leur
liberté pour vaincre l'épidémie
le cdh d'anna le sénat n'a pas marchandé
son soutien pour que le gouvernement
aient les moyens d'agir
l'efficacité de son action c'est une
chose mais en tout cas nous notre devoir
notre responsabilité c'est de lui donner
les moyens d'agir
nous l'avons fait comme nous le faisons
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
et comme nous l'avons fait aussi à six
reprises lors du précédent mandat pour
l'état d'urgence face au terrorisme
clients pas nous sommes aussi dans une
période où le terrorisme fait irruption
sinistrement notre actualité et donc
nous demandons tout simplement que le
parlement se prononce parce qu'ils
représentent les français que les
français attendent je crois que
l'exécutif se soumettent à la
représentation nationale
régulièrement pour vérifier qu'on a bien
besoin d'utiliser des pouvoirs
exceptionnels pour lutter contre le
virus
par exemple nous avons considéré que si
le gouvernement voulait faire le
confinement jusqu'à la fin de l'année
bien il faudrait que au début du mois de
décembre on décide ici au parlement s'il
était opportun de continuer à faire le
confinement pendant les fêtes de noël
c'est quand même pas rien pour nos
concitoyens et un vote du parlement
ça permet d'obliger le gouvernement à
rendre des comptes et à justifier les
décisions qu'il veut prendre le
gouvernement préfère prendre ses
décisions tout seul c'est regrettable
d'autant plus que nous avons besoin pour
faire accepter toutes ces décisions là
maximum d'unité nationale
le lieu le plus indiqué pour que cette
unité nationale s'exprime c'est tout de
même le parlement c'est là que les
français sont représentés dans leur
diversité
et c'est là que leur voix peut être
portée face au gouvernement ça peut pas
dire que le parlement dit non quand le
gouvernement ne démontre qu'il a besoin
de pouvoirs spéciaux au contraire nous
avons su dire oui mais ça veut dire que
il doit se présenter devant les élus de
la nation pour obtenir les pouvoirs qui
sont nécessaires en essayant d'être
efficace dans leur mise en oeuvre
alors par exemple vous avez réduit de 70
à 30 je crois le nombre d'habilitation à
légiférer par ordonnance est ce que sur
ce point ils ont pu conserver certaines
des modifications du sénat
mais c'est un autre sujet le
gouvernement veut non seulement avoir
des pouvoirs spéciaux pendant six mois
sans passer devant le parlement alors
que ils passaient devant le parlement
tous les deux mois dans la première
période mais en plus qu'au lieu de nous
faire voter des lois dans le domaine
économique et social par exemple dans le
fonctionnement de la justice
ils puissent prendre d'un trait plume
des décisions par ordonnance en nous
demandant de l'habilité à lesperon là
nous avons dit non nous ne pouvons pas
vous laisser les pleins pouvoirs on est
encore en démocratie dans ce pays et
nous avons réduit de 70 à 30 le nombre
des ordonnances que le gouvernement
pourrait prendre et dans certains cas de
l'uranie mais que voulez-vous faire il
nous l'a expliqué nous avons écrit
directement dans la loi ce qu'il avait
l'intention de prendre par ordonnance
mais de cette manière là on n'a pas fait
un chèque en blanc au gouvernement le
parlement dans la démocratie doit jouer
son rôle parce que le parlement
représente tous les français dans leur
diversité et les français ne réagissent
pas tous de la même façon à la crise
actuelle et aux moyens qui sont mis en
oeuvre pour y faire face et donc en
venant ici au parlement le gouvernement
s'assure d'être mieux compris les
français est de pouvoir infléchir sa
politique
regardez par exemple depuis deux jours
le sénat a entendu tous ceux qui disent
non dans tel ou tel bourgade si vous
un commerce de vêtements ou de
chaussures il n'y a pas de promiscuité
il n'y a pas de danger pour la santé
plus que quand on va chez boulanger
vient nous avons dit nous allons vous
permettre de prendre un décret pour que
les préfets puissent décider ici ou là
d'ouvrir des commerces qui sinon devrait
être fermé c'est une question de bon
sens
et bien cette mesure que nous avons
votée elle montre bien que nous écoutons
la france profonde et en l'écoutant nous
permettant au gouvernement de prendre de
meilleures mesures
c'est tout le sens du rôle du parlement
dans la gestion d'une crise le président
le gouvernement font de leur mieux mais
ils ne doivent pas être laissé tout seul
la représentation nationale la
représentation de tous les français doit
être écouté
[Musique]